on this episode we do a midnight session
in a ballpark
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is
Gary B everybody is gary vay-ner-chuk
and it's of the 253 of the askgaryvee
show and we are here in AT&T Park San
Francisco with Alexis and Hunter Pence
Alexis we did it we got you here as you
did
where thank you here yes that's true you
were really thank you for being here
welcome so Alexis watch and tell
everybody you know it's really funny
hunter obviously a very famous baseball
player and we'll get into that a little
bit Brandon my best friend is going to
read the questions and hat hunter
Brandon has you on his fantasy team
right now and tried to trade me you
during the minor-league draft for a
graphic of mine but I held off and did
not trade a graphic for you so you're
going to have to take that bit away it
is a couple games you're gonna pay for
that I'm gonna try to buy low right now
Graham is out of it yeah he's get it
done he's going to dump you in a couple
weeks but what's really interesting to
me Manor anticipation it's Alexis it's
actually very much in our world yes
YouTube blogger and more importantly and
I want to talk about the soda bit before
we get into the questions you are a real
gamer you're you have a twitch channel
yeah so so why don't you tell the
vaynernation a little bit about yourself
and that a little bit about that yeah
well I've vlog I have on YouTube let's
get like so you guys want to follow it
subscribe and there I do specialty
coffee shop reviews with Hunter when we
travel and I do a lot of the day in the
life of me with this crazy life as in
travel the city of storing the baseball
changing those three times a year and I
show what it's like to actually be in
the baseball world
we're like these traveling gypsies sort
of like you you know I get it and yes
and I show that and then I also twitch
stream on twitch TV so what are you
playing right now oh I'm sorry go ahead
oh yeah forward slash let's get Lexie
and I'm gonna shut up yep Annette in
there the shadows and right now I'm
blank Kingdom rush I really love this
game it's a tower defense
but we play anything from smash letter
comes on hunter also has his own twitch
stream and I scream I scream about I
tried stream to two times a week like I
said and I go for hours and I do and I
shouldn't smash it to Kingdom rush I was
looking for new games city skyline I
love anything strategy telling me what
watching games the you were gamer when
you were kid but then in high school
college you stop cuz around that cool
get a referral daily like whoa when your
early days what were you playing like
Super Mario I was playing through Mario
yeah so like when I was growing up I
didn't really my parents were like what
is this game II like it wasn't sure you
know like when it first came here like
we don't want to do this all you're
doing is sitting in front of the TV so I
would say like the first game that I
really got into was something called
fast masters classic oh my god oh yeah
SNES and we we on that because I bought
the games I had replayed now and I was
like I can't believe I play this game
for as long as I did that and like it
was another one Tiny Toon Adventures and
I got to throw some super street cred
her way though so we get to sometimes I
get to do little events with different
gaming companies that tell me the show
like yeah we challenged all of the
people that work at the gaming companies
in Smash bro and you dominate nasty they
don't even know it so like whenever we
get it to me yeah they think I'm just
like come in just like you know honey I
hear you're a pretty good player as well
I'm a gamer like so when you're done
with baseball are you thinking about
going into the bit like are you gonna
have a double athletic career uh well I
don't know yes I don't know if I'm gonna
be a professional gamer because they're
incredibly talent yeah on next level but
what do you best at which game yeah
that's at all whatever I put my mind to
I'm really good at it since a nighttime
telly and like there was a time there
was a time when I could have been
professional at World of Warcraft like
nothing it's like a professional thing
like there's a professional thing what
is sort of no definite it was a [ __ ]
oh yeah don't just oh wow yeah I'm not
involved in potentially is like I love
twitch streaming but I
perfect yeah hoping to run tournaments
we're opening a coffee shop it's going
to be like coffee shops board games I
love that idea
yeah can you collect magic gathering
cards I play feel the draft just sort of
like sack what a question it is nerding
up here in San Francisco mix that of
course I grew up selling all this crap
so he's like you alright let's go into
first question Andrew Connor asks how
old professional sports change in the
next 10 years
how will professional sports change in
the next 10 years Lexus I mean I think
there's gonna be a lot a bigger with
eSports pretty much I mean II Ford is
going to be just you know a biggest
competitor it's not bigger so baseball
football to the normal mainstream courts
that we know now I think we're going to
consider it it just as just as big of a
sport before anything any worth like
fighting games also yeah I definitely
think eSports is going to grow huge
because kids and I think that the live
streaming of it it's going to be a big
deal yeah I think you said you said it
much like your phone to the new TV 100%
yeah they're making they're making great
changes in baseball and sports like
football that's all yeah they'll also be
around I just think it's going to be a
var yeah it's just so important to be
alive a hundred percent I'm going to add
that I think soccer will continue to
propel the Latino population in the u.s.
I think soccer especially with the World
Cup coming to North America and I also
think UFC will continue to grow and I
think that there'll be something 10
years from now that none of us are
thinking about I hope it's okay but I
might have a career in croquet I'm going
to go to not okay it might be like
climbing or like I could I genuinely
believe that in 10 years there'll be
something emerging it won't remain
straight will be like eSports today
right I near some house something that
we can't think of the biggest thing I
remind people is in 1955 baseball
players literally had jobs during the
offseason in hardware stores to make
ends meet the heavyweight champion of
the world in boxing was the most famous
person horse-racing
was on a huge pedestal
national football was a joke like it was
a non-existent like situation so things
always always continue to change that's
right that's right
Brandon Michelle's mad abs what's the
one dream career you would have wanted
if you weren't doing what you are now
Alexis the one green career I'm doing
what I'm doing this is an easy fight
probably would have do but it snows
anything else you could do there there
is it I'm literally doing what I want to
be doing yeah I mean unless I could
maybe co-host the show with Oprah that
would be my one dream job okay well
that's good yeah hundred uh you know
your base most pretty day good it's
pretty awesome when do you want to
become a baseball player about seven
years old or wow I was like I remember
one time asking my dad I was like dad
I'm going to be a major leaguer right I
just was devastated look at your dad no
say okay don't get it in your siblings I
did brothers are very sisters and
whichever their older young over and was
he good at a small yes he made it to
roots clearly yes he blew out here was
up having like a parmesan yeah he's done
that that throws what is it so 56 yeah
in this general yeah it's late my intern
yeah my answer was is definitely like to
be the quarterback of the New York Jets
so I could take control of situation and
when seven Super Bowls
once I realized unlike hunter around
fourth grade I realized I was more
likely to own the Jets than to play for
them and that's what I've been focused
on six
Brandon Blake masters asked how many
coaches tried to change your mechanics
and how we caught him with it to stay
true to yourself well I guess this one's
for you wonderful just an all right how
many coaches have tried to change your
mechanics through the years pretty much
every one of them and yes I got it
I tried to change my
with whatever they teach me and it's
just I don't really have the ability
like the flexibility like I'm trying to
do with like field versus real is a
weird thing in baseball you feel like
you're doing one thing but you're really
not
yeah and so you know I just whatever way
they put me like I've done stuff like
down here alright Brad let's keep it go
that was easier I've been Beckett as
gentlemen in honor of Mother's Day what
is the number one way your spouse's have
helped you succeed oh oh I really like
this question you like this question
right and I'm gonna ask you actually
let's work this way yeah how about you
answer that I mean obviously you know
hunters presence is huge so that's
helped me get kind of a jump off a
platform also a hunter is a super
supportive off camera too like I really
didn't believe that I could do it on my
own but he's made me believe that I can
and I'm doing it and even though I'm
still in the beginning stages he still
encourages me just as much on my first
day as whatever day I'm on now like he's
pushed me through some pretty hard times
where I do want to give up and I'm like
uh YouTube but then Here I am in that
and I still have a passion for and I
think he he reminds me of what I what I
want the end we are talking to one of
your favorite yeah and now I am like
this is right this is been saying you
guys I was telling our friend earlier as
Gary's watching the game and I was like
this is a surreal Gary is here like I
never thought you'd be here in real life
real life like so I I read a lot of
different things like mental things
psychology things spiritual things and
I'm always saying to get better and I
get she's like wonderful to bounce
things off with and she is so good at me
not taking it so seriously of being so
hard on myself she's helped me I'm a
whole new person because she's taught me
not to take myself so seriously and
she'll remind me when I'm when I'm
like really doubt she's like you've
always said you have to be carefree you
have to let go you happen so see like
freeze my spirit where when I get into
this lump where I tie myself up I can
let go do you you is in a situation
where you'll get wound up when you're in
a hitting slump more so like fielding is
kind of a different thing right like
it's at the place where you're you know
is that where you're getting into like a
rut and you start overthinking it yeah
well you just get into ruts where like
you're not even if you're hitting good
is very timely hits or they had visited
and the team's not winning sure like
there's a lot of variables and I feel
like you find your greatest success when
you can like almost type of yourself off
of like result-oriented and we like
attitude preparation like like
everything's into I'm going to be
completely prepared I'm going to have
fun and have the attitude and
expectation like for me it's pretty
simple you know Lizzie it's unbelievable
to be able to live a life where you're
not worried about the other person you
know it's really funny to have Brandon
here I would say that I have three clear
people in my life that have done that
for me my mom Brandon and my wife
Lindsey which is literally knowing 100%
that that person's intent is pure and I
never have to worry about their
reactions which almost makes you take
them for granted you know the biggest
thing that you know Liz you know I've
been married now for 13 years and like
I'm always worried to even think her for
granted because she makes it so easy and
I travel a lot and we very much have an
old-school marriage where it's divide
and conquer right I'm working she's
taking at home which is not the
politically correct thing in today's
2017 world
so we're aligned and I guess she just
allows me to breathe easily which has an
enormous impact you know I grew up like
any competitive kind of a type which is
like when you're 15 14 you don't realize
like what a spouse that supports you it
means you know I look at a lot of my
contemporaries people I compete with in
business or on my team and they don't
have that
at that lack of stress on their chest
are overthinking things
there they dragged down because I have
it's a freedom freedom and agreement yes
and I think that's definitely something
that we yeah
yes sir you guys should high-five again
that was really yeah
last one breath is this last one good
who is it who know Lonnie okay sorry
sorry know who know Lonnie no Lonnie
asks if you could tell your high school
senior self only one thing from the
future what would it be what would have
you told your high school senior self
one thing for the future man one thing
it'd probably be listen less to what
people have to say and do which blush do
what you want and don't be afraid to
want to do it even if it's something so
stupid just do it don't do it yeah
Hunter I would probably just like
somebody see yourself like believe in
yourself
or because I was I was like super hard
work like it was all about the work and
I never thought I was doing stuff and
sometimes I almost overdid it where I
would just hate believe in yourself
trust in process I would have said
listen Gary I've got some great [ __ ]
news you're gonna be a hundred percent
right
it is all actually going to happen and
you're going to prove them all wrong
I mean that's what happened I was
branded knows brave I were literally in
the bottom 25 of our entire class like
we were ship students like Brandon was
terrible and I made him look like an
honor student
and like yeah I was a really bad school
Adam - [ __ ] dominating by the Jets
like I knew I was an entrepreneur long
before it was cool like we were making
money like we were selling stuff like we
were in a different headspace and and I
just knew it and I think and I think for
everybody was watching like that inside
voice I totally agree like who would
have thought back then the gaming would
be mainstream right like yeah like did
you hit that you Intel any what you do
no of course not and so like really
under the female ABI especially no yeah
and so for me for me I think the
question they are to bring value to
everybody is watching and wrapping up is
you know you can always settle into the
norm like when you were 18 if you're
under 30 right now you have so much time
but unless you're like you can always
get the safe job you can always go back
you can never be back at this place
where you can take high risk and do your
thing and so I encouraged it
tremendously yeah go for it
all right like it we're going to let you
ask the question of the day whatever
you'd like hundreds of comments saying
Facebook and YouTube what's your
question of the day what gets you to
describe oh I like that that you went
with a real right hook I did you want
people really whether they want real
insight yeah yeah I want to hear from
all of you guys like what makes you want
to subscribe to people anywhere on
anything on any farm Hunter toughest
picturing facing a career
baseball inside talk you're beside
Lincecum in his heyday Wow
Timmy because the hair was flopping he
was throwing 103 a right-handed
left-handed curveball
no just like what the [ __ ] yeah my man
was thank you so much can you come here
yeah this is awesome
keep asking questions we'll keep
answering
[Music]